[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
morning everyone and welcome I hope
everyone had a good first day of talks
and an even better day yesterday so just
on unwind relax my name is Bernie and
we're both software developers at a
company called geotab which is based out
of Toronto the side of our talk today is
called the loader is a lie and whether
you hate them or whether you love them
we see loaders every day in web pages on
our mobile devices you know even when I
was at the airport printing off my
boarding pass the little machine had a
little you know spinning airplane there
everywhere
anyways the main problem with with
loaders is that they're just transparent
liars and that's the that's the basis of
our talk today so just a quick outline
we're gonna go through an introduction
the history of loading spinners if you
will
programs associated the problems
associated with them and some
improvements that we can make on loading
spinners and finally we'll run through a
couple demos so before we get into the
heart of this talk I just want explain
who geotab is and what we do geotab is a
telematics or jus top is a global leader
in the telematics space for those of you
who don't know what telematics is it's
the connecting of vehicles so your cars
trucks semis etc and reporting where
they are and what they're doing we
currently have more than 1.2 million
vehicles driving around the world every
day and those 1.2 million vehicles are
generating more than 3 billion raw data
records on a on a day to day basis so as
you can see from the map we have no
shortage of GPS points and I think it's
suffice to say
we collect a lot of data we also have
the richest telematics data set in the
world and in addition to GPS we also
collect stuff you know such as weather
your wipers are going on off weather
your seatbelts plugged in whether you're
speeding taking corners too sharply or
you know breaking through too harshly
pretty much anything that the car spits
out we are we're ingesting and
collecting you can kind of think of us
as like big brother for fleets and
vehicles but you know in a good way so
besides the obvious shameless plug
the reason why I mentioning all this is
because one of the challenges that we
have with all this data is you know
taking it in and showing it into a
format that people can understand so
this could be you know dashboards charts
reports etc you know so for instance if
we have a chart that's looking at you
know several months of data it's a lot
of data and the load times can be fairly
substantial and you know to alleviate
this problem we are guilty of using a
loading spinner as well so by show of
hands who knows what a throbber is it's
the robber okay not many of you as
that's kind of I was in the same boat I
don't know what if the robber was until
I researched or until I did some
research on loading spinners and all
their counterparts so a throbber is any
animation that a computer program uses
to display to the user that work is
being done in the background so this
would be like downloading or loading a
web page or doing some kind of you know
some kind of crazy calculation and if
you're as old as I am you will recognize
these two infamous robbers for those of
you don't know the one on the left is
Internet Explorer version three and the
one on the right is Netscape Navigator
both of which are long dead so let's
fast forward a few years into the
mid-2000s Ajax or when Hejaz was
introduced I mean the during a time when
most web pages were
where most web pages required a full
page reload whenever the user did some
kind of interaction you know Ajax came
in and it wasn't quite the game changer
you know it allowed portions of the web
page to change dynamically and because
of this the robbers kind of came back
but were needed more embedded in the
site rather than in the browser
thankfully the names robbers didn't
stick sounds sounds kind of gross I
think they're better now known as
loading spinners or spinning loaders or
progress spinners or what have you
but the problem with them was that they
were used in judiciously and by that I
mean they were used without you know
really much any thought whatsoever now
pretty much if there was an ajax call
you know you could be pretty sure that
there was a loading spinner that a
company did and i think it's because of
this that we've now become quite
accustomed to seeing loading spinners
you know whatever we're waiting for
something over anything to happen right
okay let's see how loading spinners look
today as you okay this is this is taking
longer okay whatever I'll just continue
so as you heard from Bernie we are
dealing with a lot of data on daily
basis a billion strikers per day we are
getting data from different data sources
like our API or bigquery and it's really
challenging to work with those data
since we are getting we are having so
many so many number of Records of course
we are guilty for using loading spinners
for fetching those data so sorry for all
experience to us those data so we are
having so many different I'm sorry of
course
we are getting for using all the
spinners when fashion those data which
is unfortunate because some of those
queries take so much time they take so
long
so you
are not sure what's happening whether or
not it's still loading whether or not
they are its deal fetching whether or
not they're just staring at some
animated gif which is exactly what are
you doing now so slides are not broken
we are very much connected and online
and if I pull at least one of you don't
feel bad because this brings us to a
first problem with loading spinners
which is that they don't show any sign
of progress the main problem with
loading spinners is that they don't show
either completed or remaining progress
let's go back to the previous loading
spinner the 1i tries to fold you it
so besides questioning Wi-Fi
connectivity here I'm sure at least some
of you we're thinking what's happening
or how much longer we'll have to wait
well the answer on both of those
questions is I don't know so you you
just accepted the fact that something
was happening and that something was
going through a lot right so if we
replace this loading spinner with some
cool animation the user experience might
be better but we are still we're still
waiting like you are still wondering
what's happening and how much longer
we'll have to wait the next issue with
loading spinners speeders is perception
of longer loading time time flies when
you are having fun right when you're
been watching your favorite TV show on
Netflix hours just go by it's kind of
like what happened to me when I watched
the whole season of stranger things in
in a day yeah yeah that was me too hey I
see some of you as well unfortunately
waiting is the opposite of having fun
just imagine yourself being in a traffic
jam for hours and you will know exactly
what I'm talking about
sorry so the same can be said about
loading spinners they make loading
appear long they make loading appear
slower so even if you use some animation
we are still waiting right and we are
just watching it something that makes
loading that makes loading appear longer
than it actually is so the last problem
with loading spinners is that there is
there is no sign of what's coming next
in one second you are watching at on the
blank page with loading spinner and then
BAM all content just magically appears
on the screen right unless it's your
birthday or you want a Jack what these
surprises may not have a good impact on
the user the surprise effect can be
reduced with with skeleton screams if
you take a look at those two screenshots
one of them is more surprising than than
the other one on the Left we have a
loading spinner that where data is
loaded all at once and on the right we
have skeletal screen this this is less
surprising because data is content is
loaded a little bit at a time so
skeletal screens give users give users
idea of what's what's coming next
next a heads-up of what's coming next
but today really tell us how much longer
we will have to wait some content to
load or do they make the deme clothing
appears for unsurprisingly the answer is
no so what are some of the best
practices for loading spinners for
starters don't use them well that's a
bit extreme right because they are
useful and we should use them but I
would say use them in moderation which
means
if pro if process is less than one
second we really don't need a loading
spinner right
but if process takes between two and
that's ten seconds at most I would
recommend using loading spinner
ten seconds might be too much but I will
leave it up to you like it's really
depends on on the on each case okay
Brittany let's let's improve those
loading spinners okay so we cover a lot
of ground with the the loading spinners
let's see how we can become better so
the first way to improve them is to give
some feedback to the user from the
moment a user clicks on something or has
some kind of user interaction they're
basically waiting you know and if you
can give them some kind of context as to
why they're waiting they might be more
inclined to wait for the entire process
to finish this could also include what's
currently happening as part of the the
feedback loop I would say for even
longer operations
Safa it's also helpful to break down the
the process into kind of distinct parts
so for example if your if your process
is the backing up of data for a month
each day could be considered a step in a
series of you know 30 or 31 steps and
this this pretty much resembles a
progress bar which kind of goes into
this so the next way to improve the
loading spinners to display some kind of
some indication of process progress
sorry the most obvious way is with a
percentage where zero is no work and 100
is all work you've done it's pretty
obvious but of course the most obvious
way is not the prettiest way so you know
let's introduce progress bars every
knows these things or progress wheels
and these things are good for to
visualize progress because you know
everyone understands them and their
behavior is is pretty expected and
finally finally the last way is to
provide some kind of time estimate
time progress can I guess it's useful
but I find could be detrimental you know
if your time progresses like an hour and
34 minutes you might be kind of
disappointing the better way would be to
show the time remaining and you know
depending on the circumstances this can
be kind of tricky to do but I think an
approximation of that time is is is is
enough to keep the user satisfied and
kind of engaged not sure if you can see
that but it says the little picture
there says about 60 seconds remaining so
they're pretty vague all right so enough
talk you know let's let's test Murphy's
Law and do some demos in the first demo
today I'll show you how we are loading a
thousands of records and what we did to
improve those who holding spinners and
the waiting time I'll load the same data
on the bar chart and we load them in
three different ways
the data represents all trips trips
happened in periods of four months which
is approximately about two 120 20
thousand trips first let's take a look
at libraries that we used so we are
using geotab API to get those data then
we are using material for user interface
for chart rendering we are using charts
is chess and at the end we are using
rxjs to handle a synchronous events in
the first iteration I have one single
API request that returns all data and
I'm using I'm using a simple loading
spinner so let's go to the dough
No
so here we go
so let's start the demo does this
loading spinner sounds familiar from the
beginning this is not give I promise
so this was something we tried first if
you remember the problems with loading
spinners I was talking about
so this attempt had all of those
problems so there is no sign of progress
loading time appears longer than it
actually is there is not like surprise
effect is still present and like
everything went pretty pretty wrong I
would say so this is still loading I
wasn't questioning Wi-Fi connectivity
before but now I'm kinda kinda is I can
okay this should be soon I promise
I hope no one is streaming Netflix
record right now and if someone is I
hope it's in the other room at least
okay usually fix it's not that long
of course I would be shorter I would be
faster when you're doing a live demo
let's make it as longer as possible and
as as I said before now we are really
wondering what's happening we have no
idea will this ever end or what's going
so so be at the end let's wait a little
bit more if not I will just move on
because it's really shouldn't take this
long
looks like we are not lucky with demos
today yeah yeah that's fine yeah I don't
know just keep over I'll just keep going
to the other demo hopefully oh actually
here we go she's finally okay I'm so
happy I was already sweating okay before
we see the code for this I wanna I want
to take a look at this chart because it
shows some pretty interesting some
pretty pretty interesting data as I said
the data on this chart represent data
all three for four months period and
each bar represents each day we have
five bars in a row that are pretty
consistent followed by two lower ones
and those two longer ones are represent
the weekends so you can see that people
are driving less for the weekends which
is I would say expected the week with
the spike is March break in Canada so
you think you can see how number of
trips increased except especially on
Monday I guess we can't have kids at
home we just have to take them somewhere
so okay let's see the code the code for
I switch to the slides
no okay
sorry about that the code for this
iteration is very simple so here we are
just making just making an API call and
only thing that he said is just start it
pretty simple after API call is done we
are generating labels and syria's that
are used to render charts using Chartist
library in the second iteration we are
splitting up API calls into sequences
and rendering the parts as we receive
them again we are still using simple
loading spinner so let's go to the other
demo
I hope this one is one take that long is
previous one so this was this was our
second attempt and I would say first
improvement this time we are showing
some progress right that we didn't have
before it's more user-friendly because
it gives users an idea of content that
will be displayed and there is no
surprise effect the waiting time feels
shorter because users are distracted by
progress that is happening in background
so as you can see we are rendering how
we receive data we are rendering we are
rendering them in the same time so I
would say with it is really improvement
comparing to the previous example it's
really at least for me for us it was and
for our users it was it was a better
user experience so you can see here you
can see a number of records that are
loaded we are still we are coming to the
end very soon okay here we go the same
chart as I promised the same data just
in a different ways just in different
way ok let's go back to slides let's see
the code here we has some simple rxjs
code so how many of you is using our
access Wow not many to be honest I also
started using it recently and I would
highly recommend for you guys to try
because I really found it useful for
things I'm working on and I think it's
it's really good especially especially
new new new versions of of rxjs even if
you're not familiar with our FJs I can
see a lot of people isn't it's really a
simple code and you should be able to
fall to fall so here we are just
creating a simple observable for the
start buttons click it calls a start
following function that fetches the data
and repeats until some condition is
satisfied this call here should look
familiar
the only difference is that we are now
loading 10,000 records at a time the
version is used to keep track of where
we left off from the from the past API
call and here we are just subscribing to
the observable and creating a chart
until a condition is met one once we
reach the end date we just stop fetching
the data finally in the iteration three
and final iteration I'm I'm splitting up
the API call again calls again in
sequences and rendering rendering parts
how we receive them but this time I have
a brand-new fancy progress spinner so
let's see let's see this fancy spinner I
hope it's not fancy on this movie ok
let's start so this is the final
solution that solves all the problems we
had before so we finally have the full
progress Pinner
i was looking for all this time users
know what kind of content is coming how
much progress has been completed and how
much is is remaining and of course this
only works if you have a definition of
what's considered complete in our case
we are done when we reach our end date
which will happen very soon in about 40%
so you can also see here how many it's
very smile yeah you can see in the left
top corner how many days is loaded so we
are waiting for April to load and as I
said before again the same data just in
some new way and I hope this way is much
better for for you for you because it's
definitely much better for us and for
our users let's let's cool slides again
to take a quick look at code without
going into much details the purpose of
this code is to make a counter that
gives you the illusion that is
increasing smoothly I won't explain this
code in details you can find it in our
slides later and here we are just
calculating the percentage and I'm
animating the recipe let's go to - thank
you so that's pretty neat I mean a lot
of loading but it's kind of neat now we
wouldn't be at all telematics company if
we didn't show you guys something
related to the map right so let's load
him up so at the beginning of the talk I
showed you guys a map of North America
and all the GPS points plotted on that
map and it looks pretty extensive you
could see you know the major freeways
the roads or major roads and you could
really make out all the major cities and
all of that or that map pretty much
amounted to about 12 million trips but
that's not necessarily 12 million GPS
points I guess I should explain that
there's many GPS points for one trip so
maybe there was close to a hundred
million GPS points but you know as the
title of our talk says and you know for
the sake of time at bandwidth we're just
going to go to million data points or
trips
just like just so some of the tech we
used the data store is a Google bigquery
the table schema is pretty simple it's
just a long lab you know a time
associated with that with that that
point and we have a couple measurements
of driving duration in mac speed we're
using nodejs client library from Google
to query bigquery from JavaScript we're
also using deck GL which is a kind of
like a layer on top of map box that uses
WebGL I guess for for handling you know
many data points millions of data points
if you will and again we're using RS yes
so let's take a look at the demo right
so we have a map in North America I'm
just gonna click play and you know
fairly shortly we should be seeing some
points in than that not shipping so we
have a progress bar instead of the
spinner this time just to spice things
up so I'm not sure if you notice but at
the beginning I only loaded say like a
small number of records only a thousand
and then I kind of like gradually
increase it maybe a thousand two
thousand five thousand ten thousand and
so on and this is just to give the user
something to look at from the very GetGo
I think about a couple normally it takes
about a couple seconds for the first
thousand or so records to come in so it
gives the the user something to play
with right off the bat and they don't
have to wait for you know all 1 million
to the load so we're at 150 thousand
records right now which is a little
behind what I'm used to but let's assume
in here we're from Toronto so let's take
a look at Toronto you know it's the
downtown cores is little point nicely
you can see there and you know some of
the surrounding areas are also lit up if
we zoom in all the way you know we get
our we going to get a coverage of our
good indication of the coverage in
Toronto you'll see that some of the
circles are different sizes
and it really is because we made the the
size of the size of the circle a
function of speed so the larger the
circle the larger the match speed was
for that trip and then vice versa for
the small ones and then as the as the
circle is going to overlap each other it
kind of creates this this highlighting
effect which I thought was pretty neat
we can zoom out here yes we can see we
can start to make out a lot of the major
cities in on the East Coast here like
New York Detroit Chicago let's take a
look at you know Manhattan for example
so I mean there's a lot of activity in
Manhattan and it's pretty hustle bustle
right the one thing I want to notice
here there is a pretty high point right
here you know it's pretty bright and
believe it or not that's Riker Island so
I'm not sure if you guys know what that
is but that is a prison so it's from
from this we can tell that you know
there's a lot of activity going on in
the prison you know a lot of trips
coming in and out whether it's inmates
or food or whatever we don't know but
there are a lot of trips I just a word
of advice
stay out of there and don't be part of
that statistic so let's zoom out a bit
more we're almost reaching the 3/4 mile
way there or 3/4 way there you know we
got Florida lit up quite nicely on the
East Coast again all the major cities we
come to the west coast we can we can see
a lot of the you can actually make out
some of the major major freeways now
even some of the roads san francisco's
is is pretty busy looks better when the
zoom there and LA of course is just you
know insane it looks like the traffic
there the traffic map is just it's crazy
so I mean I'm not gonna wait for the
rest of it to load it's taking a bit
longer than usual but you guys get the
idea right and it's pretty mean when you
zoom out or Mexico City is just insane
too but
whatever all right so let's take a look
at some of the the code I'm just going
to go through this pretty quickly
because you know it's not nothing -
nothing too crazy we're loading a table
I called trip to North America which
completely makes sense and it comes from
a some kind of data set we had called or
for this bill for this conference of J's
cough demo the rest of is just kind of
for authentication purposes really so we
take our table and then we're calling
get rose and get rose takes in two
parameters that are the first is options
and the good thing about options that
it's if resembles our API pretty clear
pretty pretty closely in that it takes
in a match results which is say like 50
thousand records and then with that 50
thousand and we also get a kind of got
pointer to the to the very last record
which we use in our subsequent calls to
get the next 50 thousand and so on and
then finally a callback just sends back
the data and the the pointer that I
talked about just now so this is just
some initialization code for map box
nothing crazy here I guess the only
thing I want to point out is that Dec GL
handles all the interactions instead of
map box so that's why we have this
interactive flag set to false so with
deck GL we start by creating a deck this
is all pretty pretty simple stuff again
and as mentioned previously whenever the
state changes it's handled by this
function and it keeps both deck GL and
the map in sync some of our X J's code
so we get back data from the Google
bigquery API and it's it's putting it to
an observer or observable
our observer here we subscribe to it and
then we're creating a layer that we put
on to deck GL for our purposes we're
using a scatter plot layer and we're
just using the
we got from bigquery now the data looks
like this that's pretty simple again
there's a position which is an array of
long and lats there's a radius I think
it's I think it's in pixel but I'm not
really sure you can also use it you can
also use a function instead of a number
and of course we have a color some RGB
value so that's that's the end of our
demos and in summary so by no means are
these what we talked about
hardened rules for using loading
spinners or progress spinners but it's
more it's more for you to consider you
know that's something to think about the
next time you're making an async all if
you're using a loading spinner
you know just use some good judgment
for anything else that takes longer if
you can use a progress spinner or or
something that at least gives the user
some kind of feedback right you know if
you do so your users will probably
appreciate the the improved loading user
experience but I think more importantly
they're going to thank you for not lying
boldly to your face so that concludes
our talk thank you guys for listening
thank you both for that wonderful
wonderful talk can we get another round
of applause for both so the next talk is
going to start at 10:15 unfortunately we
don't have a spinning loader for the
next couple minutes so you're just gonna
have to use the forward progress of time
as your loader but yeah 10:15 is going
to be the next talk so have a good
conversation while you're waiting
you